alors toi tu voulais nous raconter un
truc parce que j'ai pensé le jour parce
que j'ai un pote qui me disait au
téléphone parce que j'ai fait une
Saint-Valentin un peu rigolote et j'ai
un pote qui me dit c'est où l'endroit le
plus incroyable où tu as fait l'amour
dans ton cul
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est là où j'ai scotché mes potes je
dis dans une cabine d'essayage
mais là où l'historait folle c'est que
c'était pas avec mon
copains
[Rires]
j'ai eu au péage de Saint-Arnoult
il va payer pour la gare
j'ai vu la dernière fois au péage de La
Queue-en-Brie
parce qu'on est vraiment des gens à part
attention une fois j'étais au Club Med
de sport je dis pas quoi
de sport
un club de je vais dans le vestiaire il
y a un gars
j'aurais voulu dessiner la beauté je
vous aurais décidé vous et puis après
lui et magnifique et je vois qu'il me
regarde je le regarde on va il y a
hammam tous les deux non hammam regarde
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais comment tu fais alors vous avez
changé l'eau
jacuzzi vous avez changé l'eau quoi ah
oui
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable c'est fou oui et donc
non mais si j'avais su qu'il avait un
copain si j'avais su si j'avais su qu'il
avait un truc
c'est pas une interview moi
ça y est tu vas pas nous raconter non
mais c'est vrai j'étais content de vous
voir on s'en fout là c'est bon là
boubouski mange Booba MAM moi je vous
montre mais
c'est bon non mais ça déconnecte
énormément je vous
voilà mais c'est bon quoi on a eu zéro
Mons Booba randonnée c'est bon pourquoi
on me demande à moi de pas être vulgaire
[Applaudissements]